[Music]
now as I mentioned Julian Castro the
mayor of San Antonio Texas gave the
keynote speech last night at the
Democratic National Convention the
problem wasn't if you saw this but while
he was talking giving this very
important speech they kept cutting away
two shots of his adorable three-year-old
daughter take a look today my beautiful
wife Erica and I are the proud parents
of a three-year-old little girl gottena
Victoria as a dad I'm gonna do my part
and I know she'll do hers but our
responsibility as a nation is to come
together and do our part you know I you
know yes she's very cute very adorable
but a lot of people are now saying they
don't even know if Castro gave a good
speech or not because they were too
distracted by his daughter I think this
is a real problem when someone has
something important to say you shouldn't
draw attention away with shots of
someone acting cute now don't get me
wrong
[Music]
I like cute as much as the next guy I
really do
but there's a time and a place for that
stuff it's not when someone's trying to
make an important point you don't do it
you know the chance to reach a national
audience comes right at all - and
frequently you can't just throw it away
so TV directors get tracked together put
the focus where it should be keep it on
the substance none on silly little eye
candy because otherwise as a nation we
lose sight of what's really important to
end up wandering into the wilderness of
triviality and fluff and then we all get
distracted
thank you I appreciate it
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
where did the cat